[Music]
so you're telling me that we finished
the album and we're about to go on tour
yeah and until we go on tour we have to
stay here at this nice place and we have
to cut you we have to cook for everyone
yeah I mean that's what the bossman says
[Music]
as we said cook for everyone yes Sean
said that we were cooking that makes
zero sense that's not even funny like
it's not even a funny concept that's
horrible why like cuz we're gonna [ __ ]
it up so bad never doubt yourself bro
alright I guess I guess let's do it
alright let's get it can't it can't be
too bad yeah Jodi where oh this way yo
and rich Brian I'm Joe G and we're
celebrating the eighty arising head in
the clouds album and tour by cooking for
our friends at our end of summer party
house the thing is though I don't think
we really know how to cook welcome to
the feast mansion welcome to the feast
mansion welcome to the feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion
[Music]
you know what up this fish Brian this is
Jodi and we're back at fees mansion and
today we're gonna learn how to make on
your ice because we can't do it
ourselves because we're stupid
so we're gonna invite Chef Ludo here
so chef you wanna make me over here you
can please come on up yeah guys Saba oh
you guys know something it's great to
meet you guys
nice to meet you guys you know how to
cook eggs first how do i you know how
leuco eggs you know what so eggs dude
honestly this is my first time seeing
eggs in my life you know so eggs you
know sometimes I think fun cool you know
what yeah yeah the brown ones come from
the male eggs actually that the male
produces the eggs and the white one is
the females right on it very very easy
to do when you practice a lot yes yeah
it's a lot about technique okay of
course first you need eggs okay
nonstick span 9 inch 9 inch Oh 18 has to
be it has to be 9 inch has to be okay
oh well you want when you put your
omelet you know the pan be 1 but not too
well and no coloration no seasoning okay
because cooking an omelet is with using
your here okay cooking visually with
your here hello hi what this ain't it no
he said no sizzling right yeah this is
like yeah this is Inc see touch a tooth
touch no touch it okay
there's no too hard to see as well so
she's very nice very well that's good
right now we put it over there okay
sorry
alright okay so you can hear there's no
seasoning so yeah you don't want to be
aggressive when you cook an omelet it's
got need to be not a project to be
gentle gentle gentle
so we make sure the eggs don't stuck in
the pan and you don't want to burn the
eggs okay so you just RINO like a few
drinks combine eggs I'm going to put
some books and cheese in the omelette du
fromage
oh you study yeah under the format' yeah
yeah
garen you can say that when go to France
you would read in your net orphanage
yeah I'd get by
[Music]
but crews not guys you need to eat after
okay yeah yeah well net okay see huh so
it's like scrambled eggs and I've told
you let's set do you think my restaurant
before
no no support guys thank you very much
yeah good yeah no time we really want to
go where is it this is our first time
meeting you really put some cheese over
their books and cheese I love this
flavor of the cheese but also they melt
very well in the minute okay well net
yeah is set okay uh-huh
I'll tell you and go over there and
you're going you're just oh I like that
it's okay it's not a beautiful job you
that works without you guys know what
that means okay good
I've never feel more alive hey guys wow
I'm oh my god
this is I'm not even kidding this is the
best I've ever came in my life
dude this is like literally something
that you can make at home now that came
out of a chicken thighs dude yeah that's
you can ask you right this is crazy dude
Chef Ludo thank you so much for this
really you really taught us yeah well
we're gonna try to make our own right
now but you know I really appreciate
this fact that I can make this at home
just blows my mind
all right since we originally set out to
make omurice it's good that we've
learned how to make an omelet yeah
because now we can double-team this yeah
so you're gonna make the fried rice yeah
yeah I'll make the fried rice
yeah I'm gonna make the omelets and yeah
you can just watch over so just like let
us know we're focused anything address
coaching okay okay just mentally abused
us sir okay
[Music]
to understand you know one is very messy
one is very clean
Brian is very very very gentle little
faster as you work it looks more like
Virginia because wow so I'll try moving
forward how am i doing chef
he's right can't wait to try it Suzy
yeah yeah check out that was really good
thank you thank you
I see buddy but I'm just cool little bit
like that size a size more is equal to
MC yes
great yeah putting backward like that
Wow not bad for your first X boot oh
thank you okay
alright guys I'm about to flip the
omelet so let's hope I don't [ __ ] this
up no don't shake any foot sing go what
do you like to get married Wow
thank you I want your girlfriend's
emotion yeah yeah so I'm kind of
coaching my arm over here Jodi how you
doing I'm doing good I think I uh
I tasted it a second ago it was kind of
kind of tasted yeah yeah I I fixed it
that I think then yeah I believe so
[Music]
all right so I got my omelet Georgie's
got the fried rice and put about the
joint forces now we got a mold the rice
[Music]
that's nice Wow right now I'm gonna move
the omelet to the right she's beauty
food I hope I don't know you can okay no
okay oh but what if I do break it though
you stopped again comes that way papa Oh
a wife for another day we're gonna cut
it open like those people on Instagram
and I hope it opens up okay yeah but it
looks nice well this is our you know
non-traditional kind of take on it I
mean it's very sexy can I try that can I
take the first set yeah all right mmm
oh hang on yeah right
nothing is wrong ketchup cheese is
really gonna eggs
[Music]
[Music]
it was am it's quite good fit also
source - yeah thank you yeah would you
rate this dish five of the ten yeah
that's not bad yeah that's like a damn
mmm the finger I love the texture of
energy absorb net which is very soft and
you have your high schools or mores
almost more crunchy but not really but
textures good so we're actually about to
have a party we're gonna have some
friends over do you want to like just
stick around like crack a few beers open
you know you know and we do a meta
morning yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they go
well you you did omelettes okay
character right stomach the rights to
know please do boom here you go guys the
army rice try to hold we got history
Finland in the statue would you look at
me
could happen no what could a bit finally
your face I know that aside you see take
my time to take your clothes off one
more time baby I can't let you don't be
calling and impressing me
Megan goes but you fit better wrinkle
tea we moved under
[Music]